- Okay, good afternoon.
Welcome to re:Invent
and welcome to the Future of Kubernetes,
which I admit is a bit of a
mysterious sounding title,
but I assure you we're gonna
cover a real concrete overview
of recent enhancements to EKS,
as well as a sneak preview
of what's coming in the
next couple of years.
It was probably six to nine months ago
and Netflix came to us with a vision
that I imagine some of you
in the audience have had
where they said, "We
want to use Kubernetes,
but we want to make scale and operations
somebody else's problem."
And I'm lucky enough today to be joined
by Niall Mullen, who's the senior director
of cloud infrastructure at Netflix,
and he's gonna talk about
how Netflix migrated to EKS
in a matter of months, not years.
And then, I'm gonna cover how
we're making that philosophy
available to all customers,
no matter their size.
And we're also joined by Eswar Bala,
who's the director director
of Engineering and Containers,
and he's gonna talk about
some of the scaling innovation
we've done over the last year to make sure
that we support the very large
scale that Netflix runs at.
Okay, Kubernetes, I assume
everybody in this room
is familiar with the word.
This is the data from the
latest CNCF survey in 2024,
which says that now 80% of enterprises
are using Kubernetes in production.
I think that's up from 66%
when it was done in 2023.
So, over 90% of companies out
there are at least evaluating,
if not using, Kubernetes at this point.
And, you know, why is that the case?
Why has Kubernetes become so popular?
Simplicity, in our view,
is the biggest reason
why it's become that way.
I think there was a recent
tweet that said something like,
"Kubernetes is the wrapper of,
you know, 15 years of bash
scripts, runbooks, cookbooks
that SREs have made, all wrapped up behind
a simple to use, declarative,
reconciling set of APIs."
And that really resonated with me
and what I've heard
from customers as well.
Kubernetes is a very simple way
to manage your cloud infrastructure.
The other two that come up are consistency
and extensibility.
With simplicity, first, you're
never starting from scratch
when you're using Kubernetes.
If you need to run a Spark job,
you go use the Spark operator.
You need to run an ML training job,
you go to a project like Kubeflow.
Very rarely are you starting from scratch.
And that's simple, you
don't have to write a lot
of custom stuff.
Consistency is the other one
that we hear a lot from customers.
You can run Kubernetes on AWS, on-prem,
and other clouds, on the
Edge, on fighter jets,
which we've seen with EKS.
You can run it anywhere.
And then extensibility,
while Kubernetes is simple,
it doesn't cover every single
use case you might need.
And while Kubernetes, by default,
is a container orchestrator,
really with the CRD model
and its extensibility,
you can customize it
to do anything you want.
And we see more and more customers today
starting to use EKS and Kubernetes
to operate their entire business,
not just orchestrating containers.
So we announced EKS back
in 2017 at re:Invent,
or the, I believe, a preview of it.
So, it's now been eight
years since we launched EKS.
And we've advanced from,
you know, the early days
where it was just to manage
Kubernetes control plane.
We've launched open source projects
that have become the new standard
in the Kubernetes ecosystem.
We've expanded beyond the control plane
to do add-ons, data plane,
and today we'll cover what
our latest expansion is,
EKS capabilities that we
announced just last night.
So, Kubernetes in context.
You know, your goal is to
deliver business value,
not necessarily operate infrastructure.
And our goal is to deliver
the fundamental components
that you need to build
a production-ready Kubernetes environment.
And what does that mean?
At the infrastructure layer,
compute, networking, storage,
none of that's ever gonna change.
And one of our jobs on the EKS team
is to make sure you get those
fundamental building blocks
that AWS gives in a Kubernetes native way.
Things like our CNI that
integrates with the VPC,
or Karpenter with integrates with EC2,
or our storage drivers
within integrating with storage services.
That foundation is super important.
We're always investing there.
Then the control plane, right?
That's the hardest part
of doing Kubernetes,
not for the faint of heart.
Nearly everybody who's running
Kubernetes on AWS these days,
including Netflix now, is using EKS.
They're not doing it themselves.
Management, tooling, governance,
compliance, security,
that's the next layer you have on top.
We've expanded to start to help you there.
And then, developer tooling.
I said in that earlier slide
that I think 80% of customers
are evaluating Kubernetes now.
Some recent data has actually shown
that developer familiarity
with Kubernetes is decreasing.
And while you might say,
"Oh, is that a, you know,
Harbinger Kubernetes
is losing popularity,"
we actually see it's the opposite.
And that Kubernetes is just
becoming a layer in the stack,
like say Linux has
become, where developers
don't really have to have to
think about Kubernetes anymore.
They just use their familiar
tooling, deployments,
IDPs, Jobs, ML workflows,
and that runs on Kubernetes underneath,
but it's not something
they have to be terribly familiar with.
I wanna talk briefly about
container registry in ECR.
I think it's the unsung hero
of the AWS container world
and it's something
myself and Eswar focus on
in addition to Kubernetes.
So, I'll go through quickly
some of the advancements we've made
in the container registry space.
ECR does over 2 billion image pulls a day.
I think we like to think of
as the unsung hero of
AWS container services.
Every application, you're running
in a container orchestrator,
if you're using ECR,
it's starting with an
image pulled from there.
Some recent enhancements we've made.
Enhanced scanning, we did an
integration with Inspector,
where we provide advanced
scanning for images.
And one of the features that
we're most excited about,
and I think myself and Eswar
especially talk a lot about
how can we do better together
across container services,
how can EKS, ECS, ECR work better.
And this is one of those
examples where we said,
"How can we make, you know,
security folks lives easier?"
We run a scan. You get a
report of a vulnerable image.
Well now, where is that running?
You might have dozens,
hundreds, thousands of clusters
depending on the environment
you're running back.
So, this feature we
launched a few months ago
makes it easier to see a live
inventory of vulnerable images
that are running.
Another one is authenticated
pull through cache.
And one of the enhancements we made
was ECR to ECR pull through cache.
With ECR, we let you pull
images from upstream registries,
like Docker Hub, but
you can, in ECR public,
but you can now also pull within
your own ECR repositories.
So that's across regions, across accounts,
and that's a feature we
made earlier this year.
Some other notable 2025 launches.
And the one I wanna
highlight, I think this was,
I'll talk about the containers
roadmap in a little bit.
I believe the highest upvoted issue
on the entire containers roadmap
was this tag immutability one,
where certain images you wanna upload
and they can never change.
There's security and compliance reasons.
But the latest tag specifically,
often in development
workflows, you are okay,
you do wanna change that.
And within a repo, we now
give you that flexibility
where you can set certain
tags, for example, latest
to have image immutability.
And then, our two new
launches for re:Invent.
One, archival.
We talked to a lot of ECR customers
that when you get to a certain
scale for compliance reasons,
they still need to keep images around.
However, you know, you can be running up
terabytes of storage that
you don't necessarily need.
You may need someday because
an auditor compliance
come back and says you need it.
But you don't need that
in your primary registry
to be pulled down for actual usage.
And so with ECR archival,
we now give you an easy way,
meaning we can, you can look at the time
an image was last pulled to decide
if you wanna archive an image
and put that into a separate storage class
that comes at a lower price.
If you do for whatever
reason need that image back
eventually to run in workloads,
you can bring it back from
the archive storage class.
Very similar to services like S3,
which have different
tiers of storage classes.
We now have that in ECR.
And then, the last one in
ECR managed in image signing,
you're always gonna hear
about security in an AWS talk.
It's always one of the
top things we think about.
We now provide managed signing in ECR,
and so, you don't have to
run separate infrastructure.
It's fully automated and it's
integrated with AWS Signer.
It's integrated with all
of your, you know, tools,
you know, in AWS like CloudTrail.
Now with a simple API
call, you can sign an image
and have that automatically done in ECR.
Okay, onto on or back to Kubernetes.
So EKS.
We run lots of clusters,
tens of millions of clusters.
This is tracking the
number of create calls
we see to our API over
the course of the year.
And I think we all agree
Kubernetes is awesome,
but Kubernetes is hard to run.
We make it a point in EKS
that we are always gonna run vanilla,
upstream Kubernetes.
Conformance is super important to us.
We're never gonna run
a version of Kubernetes
that differs from what
you get in upstream.
If your workload runs in
Kubernetes somewhere else,
it's gonna work in EKS
and that's a super important tenet for us.
Okay, I'm gonna now cover quickly
a lot of the enhancements we've made
over the course of the
year for EKS upgrades.
It's a word that probably
makes a lot of you
in this audience shudder when
you hear about Kubernetes
and EKS.
I think, you know, death
taxes, Kubernetes upgrades.
When you make the choice
to adopt Kubernetes,
upgrades are just something
you have to stay up with.
We recognize that we know it's painful,
but when you're any
managed open source service
that you're adopting AWS
generally has upgrades.
So, a few things we've done this year.
Cluster insights, we scan your clusters.
We look for certain things
that may impact your ability
to upgrade to the next
version of Kubernetes.
Are you using deprecated APIs?
Are you running a (indistinct) version
that's more than two versions behind?
There's a whole host of things we look for
and we surface that to you for upgrade
in through upgrade insights.
You can now refresh that on demand.
One of the pieces of feedback
we had heard was great.
You surface to that once a day.
If I go fix that, it takes too long for me
to figure out if it was addressed or not.
And then, the other one I'll mention
is Kubernetes version
support acceleration.
We've put a lot of effort in
over the last couple years
to make sure we stay up to
date on Kubernetes versions.
They come out every four months now.
If you look over the last two years,
I believe every single
release of a version in EKS
has been within 45 days.
If you had talked to
us a couple years ago,
we were not there.
We've put in a lot of work
to make sure that's the place.
And you can be assured that moving forward
within that 45 day window,
new versions will be available in EKS.
Here's just a screenshot upgrade insights.
I feel like it's a hidden feature.
I talk to customers and they're like,
"Oh, we didn't even
know you surfaced that."
So, it's available in the console.
If you go to the monitor
cluster dashboard,
these we run every day by default.
You can now upgrade them yourselves.
But this is every time
we release a new version,
we're going and checking
is there something new
we should look for.
I think in 1.33, we started checking,
are you using Amazon Linux 2,
because that's no longer
supported in 1.33.
So this is something we're
always improving over time,
adding new things to look
for as new versions come up.
One of the pieces of feedback
that I got from customers is,
"Great, we need to upgrade.
I don't even know which
clusters I need to go upgrade."
I have clusters across dozens of accounts,
dozens of regions, account managers
reaching out to me saying,
"Hey, can you go figure out
where all my customer's clusters are?"
Because they know they need to upgrade,
they just can't find them.
And as customers run more clusters
across these various boundaries,
we knew we needed an easy
way to make it viewable
where those clusters are.
So, we did a lot of research.
There's various services in AWS
that had regional multi-region dashboards.
Others that had like EC2, I
believe, has a global console.
Other services had
cross-account dashboards backup.
Nobody as far as we knew had yet done
a true global cross-account,
cross-region dashboard.
And we knew if we had to solve
this problem of figuring out
what's going on across my clusters,
that we had to solve both of those things.
So earlier this year, we launched
this EKS global dashboard,
which gives you a centralized inventory
of all of your clusters.
It's not necessarily meant
as a high severity troubleshooting.
It's more of an executive level dashboard.
You log in Monday morning,
your cup of coffee.
Let's see what versions clusters are on,
who do I have to go chase for upgrades.
It's that type of workflow
where you just need to
understand what is the state
of all my Kubernetes clusters look like.
We've continued to work on observability,
making it easier to
understand what's going on
in your cluster, troubleshoot issues.
This monitor cluster button
that's now there in the EKS console,
there's a whole bunch
of sections of it now.
You can see Node Health.
One of the ones that I
think is also kind of hidden
that is super helpful is we surface
through CloudWatch Log Query Insights,
you can see who are the top
talkers to the API server.
We see a lot of cases, tickets opened,
and it turns out, you
know, some new deployment,
a policy agent got released in the cluster
and it started making
thousands of list calls
and it took down the API server.
You run this query.
It makes it immediately obvious
that it was some deployment that did that.
Networking,
I'm sure Eswar and his
team will agree with me.
You know, we've seen every possible way
that Kubernetes can fail
over the seven years
we've been doing EKS.
A lot of the time, most of
the time, it's networking.
And feedback we got from customers was,
"Look, we'd rather not have
to open support tickets.
We'd much better off if you
can give us the visibility.
We can troubleshoot ourselves.
It's often, you know, something
going on in environment.
We need more visibility
into what's going on."
And so, we spent a lot of time
understanding those needs.
And last week, we launched
enhanced container network observability.
So this is, it's a single
agent you run in your cluster
that exposes metrics, ships
them to CloudWatch as well.
It's useful for proactive
network monitoring.
So understanding, you
know, are you nearing
DNS packet limits, are you
like retransmission timeouts.
All of these ways that
like Kubernetes networking
I think got a lot of things right.
It's a single flat networking namespace.
It's a pod, an IP per pod.
When it works, it's great.
When it doesn't, it can
be hard to troubleshoot.
And so, we're really
excited about this one.
It's an easy way to turn it on.
You get out of the box visualizations,
which I believe I have here.
So for many years,
I've wanted this one to show
the pod networking flow.
So once you turn this on,
you get a native service map
so you can understand
what are the, you know,
which pods are even talking to each other.
Oftentimes, that's the first point
when it comes to figuring out
what's a networking issue going on.
And then two, the flow view,
you can see within the
cluster who's talking to who.
And you can see both cross AZ,
you can see pod to service.
So today, we support S3 and Dynamo.
In a lot of cases, ML training
does a lot of chatting to S3.
We make that easy to understand.
And then also pod to traffic
external to the cluster.
So check this one out.
It really help with
understanding what's going on
in the networking observability space.
Another recent launch, and
this again comes a lot down
to troubleshooting, is
troubleshooting is hard,
but it's easier if you
have the right context.
We launched a MCP server
earlier this year in preview
and a lot of the feedback was,
"This is good, but until
you manage it for us,
we're not actually gonna
use it in production."
And so, we launched last
week a hosted version
of the EKS MCP server.
It's available in a public preview.
Troubleshooting and getting started
are the really two first
big use cases we have.
Troubleshooting, especially, we have,
again, seven years of EKS,
we've seen all the way Kubernetes can fail
and we have run books
and troubleshooting books
that are built into the MCP server.
So if you ask it
something that's going on,
we can go use that to go
look up the same knowledge
that a support team might
look up when you open a case.
You can now do that yourself
through this MCP server.
And it's integrated with all
of the tools you're used to,
Q console, and security,
of course, CloudTrail,
the hosted version.
All of those enterprise
grade features that you need
to actually use it in
production, you can now do.
It's integrated into Q.
So if you go into the EKS
console now, as of last week,
and you see something that's failed,
whether it's a, you know, a pod
that's crashed loop back off
or I don't know, some networking issue
with the new feature I just
talked about, you can now click.
Hey Q, tell me what's going on.
It automatically integrates
with the MCP server behind the scenes.
You don't have to do that yourself.
And this can be helpful
to understand more quickly
what's going on in your environment.
For an even deeper level of observability,
CloudWatch container insights,
this product has come a long
way in the last two years
and we recently launched EBS metrics,
more detailed GPU metrics,
application signals support.
Look, there's lots of
observability tools out there
that you might be using.
CloudWatch Container Insights
is our native version.
That's the easy button.
If you don't wanna have to think
about which metrics do I scrape,
which alarms do I set up,
just give me the opinionated version
of a Kubernetes monitoring stack.
This is gonna be your answer.
When you move to Kubernetes,
you get a lot of
efficiency benefits, right?
You're not running a single app per VM,
you're getting that bin packing
where you can have multiple applications
running on the same instance.
And that has a lot of benefits,
but it comes at the
expense of cost visibility.
It's hard to figure out
with multiple applications
running on the same instance
who's actually contributing
most to the cost.
So, we have several options there.
We have a partnership with Cube Cost,
which is an open source tool.
We have an EKS version. You can run that.
That's still an agent you
have to run in your cluster.
For the fully managed version
that you can check a box,
there's no additional cost.
We now integrate with
split cost allocation
and we announced this last year,
but two of the biggest feature requests
that we heard following that were support
for Kubernetes labels.
So not just understanding
at a namespace level
what's the cost, but at
an individual label level
on deployments, as well
as support for GPUs.
So, these were two of
the big feature requests
that are, as of several weeks
ago, now supported in EKS.
Okay, a couple more
cross-account Pod Identity.
We launched Pod Identity last year
to make it easier to connect
or authenticate from
your pods and deployments
to AWS services like
RDS, or S3, or Dynamo.
And I think this was honestly
a lesson learned for us.
Almost all of you are
running multiple accounts.
When you're running real
world production workloads,
you might have, you
know, your applications
in a separate account and
your compute in another.
And so, making PO identity
work for cross-account
was a big request.
Once we launched that feature,
we made that work this year.
There's enhancements, like
session token support.
So you can do say things
with Pod Identity,
like pod in this namespace
can only read from S3 bucket
if it has the prefix that's
the same as the namespace
and you don't need to have 10
different policies to do that.
You can do that with a single
policy using session tags.
Cluster deletion production.
There are a lot of mission
critical workloads running on EKS
and you know, a simple
thing like an infrastructure
is code tool bug that you clicked
plan and you clicked apply
and it did something
you didn't want to do.
We heard that as a real risk
from a lot of customers,
like, "hey, we have really,
really critical workloads
running in EKS."
Simple feature.
We added cluster deletion from production
that's similar to what
other services have.
EKS add-ons.
We launched this a while back now,
but we've continued to expand this.
This isn't that theme of, you
know, I wanna run Kubernetes,
but I just want AWS to take
on more of the heavy lifting.
We launched community add-ons this year.
So some of the most add-ons
we see people running in their clusters,
metrics server, external
DNS, those are now available
for you as well.
And then, another feature
that we just launched
is Backups support for EKS.
Similar mission critical
workloads, stateful workloads.
We wanted to make it easier for customers
to both backup and show
compliance to their auditors.
AWS Backup support for recast launched
I believe a couple weeks ago at CubeCon.
It's agentless. It's fully managed.
It works across all of
your other AWS services
that are all integrated with backup.
It works cross-account, cross-region.
So this one outta the box we believe
will cover most of the use
cases you need to back up.
And then, restoring.
You can restore just specific name spaces.
You can restore to existing
clusters or to new clusters.
It's a pretty flexible approach.
EBS definitely one of the
jobs of the product team
is to make sure that the rest of AWS
are building Kubernetes native
integrations that work well.
And EBS is a good example of a team
that we've worked really closely with.
And so, they've launched recent features
like, you know, enhanced data protection,
faster initialization, volume cloning,
all of these as the day
they launched an EBS,
they were available in
the EBS CSI drivers.
I think EBS is a good example of a case
where we work closely
with another service team
to make sure that their
innovations and their features
can come to EKS as soon
as they're launched.
Okay, I am gonna go quickly through these.
EKS runs everywhere you need to be.
We're a launch blocking service.
We are in every region. We are
in every availability zone.
That'll continue to be the case
We've run anywhere you need to be,
whether that's fully in
the cloud or on-premises
and we have a whole spectrum
of offerings available
to help you there.
Last year at re:Invent,
we announced Hybrid Nodes.
This is our newest approach
to supporting on-premises infrastructure.
So you can have the
control plane in the cloud,
worker nodes on-premises,
which is a better way
of doing in our case,
as long as you can have
connectivity to the cloud
versus EKS anywhere, which we
launched several years back,
which is a fully on-premises
air gap approach to running clusters.
But Hybrid Nodes is an easier approach
to running on-premises
if you have that connectivity
back to the region.
Some of the features
we launched this year,
Bottlerocket support,
expanded support for Cilium.
And then, configuring
networking on-premises
can be difficult.
So, we surface a lot of
insights as that setup goes.
Auto Mode was our other big
launch of re:Invent last year.
Auto Mode is our fully managed data plane
and we've launched various
features over the years,
managed node groups, carpenter.
We've EKS, Fargate.
We've learned a lot of things.
And Auto Mode, we think
is the most Kubernetes native conformant,
but fully managed data plane
that takes away the heavy
lifting you need to do.
And the way we did this
is we worked with EC2.
So previously without Auto Mode.
you're running the EC2 instances,
you're running all the
controllers in your cluster.
With Auto Mode, we take on responsibility
for running the controllers.
So things like the EBS driver, Karpenter,
the low balancer controller,
we run those on our side.
EC2 manage instances run in
your account, but managed by us.
And that was an innovation
we worked with EC2
to make happen.
We've continued to to iterate
on Auto Mode this year.
Static capacity advanced
networking options
was a big ask to support running pods
in separate subnets.
Region expansion, faster image pull.
We'll continue to iterate on Auto Mode
and there's a link
there to the change log.
Almost every week, we're launching
new features based there.
Okay, and my last one, before
I hand it off to Eswar.
Probably our biggest update to EKS really
since we launched seven years ago.
You get a cluster and
it's production ready,
but that's not enough to
actually run your applications.
How do you deploy applications
to those clusters?
Those applications generally
need other AWS services.
Maybe you need an S3 bucket,
you need an ElastiCache.
How do you provision those
and make it easy to
connect to the workloads?
So, we announced the EKS
capabilities last night.
And this is our take of
expanding beyond the cluster
to managing that heavy
lifting of the platform
that everybody's building
around Kubernetes.
And we started with both deployments.
So, we now have a managed
version of Argo CD.
Generally, our take with capabilities
is when there's an
existing community standard
that the majority of
our customers are using,
we're just gonna take that
and manage it for you.
And so, that's what we did with Argo.
It's very loosely opinionated.
If it works in Argo,
it's gonna work in this,
but also where possible, we're
gonna make AWS integrations
that make sense and make better.
So, Secrets is a pain point with GitOps.
We added a native integration
with Secrets manager
to make that easier.
Setting up credentials to
get can be challenging.
So we have a integration with CodeCommit.
And I think one of the
most underrated innovations
that we have with our
version of managed Argo
that you can't do when
you manage it yourself
is we manage the networking
sync traffic behind the scenes.
So this works cross-account.
It works cross-region.
You don't have to worry
about network connectivity
across those boundaries.
That's handled by us.
And then, the other one we
launched is managed capabilities
for ACK and KRO.
These are two open source projects.
ACK, we launched several years back.
This is a Kubernetes native
way to manage AWS resources.
And then, KRO is a way
to build abstractions
around those resources
and publish those as APIs.
And we see this is really useful
for a common pattern we see now
is rather than using
traditional infrastructure,
cloud formation, or Terraform,
where a developer needs an S3 bucket.
They go to a team. They open a ticket.
They get their bucket. They come back.
They hook it up.
Now, they define their infrastructure
alongside their Kubernetes applications
all in a Kubernetes native way.
And yeah, the customer experience.
So as an EKS administrator,
you're creating the
capability as a developer.
They're using the familiar
tools they're with,
just as if they were using 'em
in them in the open source.
And so putting it all together
as self-managed platform
with EKS looks like this.
When you combine it with
capabilities in Auto Mode,
we're managing a lot more
of the pieces for you.
Okay, with that, I'm gonna
hand it over to Eswar,
who's gonna talk about some
of the large scale innovations
we've made this year to support running
really, really large workloads on EKS.
Thanks.
- Thank you, Mike.
As Mike highlighted, Kubernetes
simplicity and extensibility
made it the go-to platform
for containerized workloads.
Now, what I wanna share
is how we are taking EKS
to unprecedented scales
to meet the demands of AI
and ML workloads.
The innovations I'm about
to show enable capabilities
that seemed outta reach
just few years back.
Let's dive in.
Now, we observed three key developments
that are shaping the
Kubernetes and AI landscape.
First, Kubernetes has
become absolutely central
to AI and ML operations.
This is not by accident.
You know, it's declarative
and extensive model.
The robust orchestration capabilities
and the rich community tooling
is exactly what makes
complex AI workloads easier.
The second development
is about the scaling loss
that we observe right now.
Increasing models sizes correlate
with the model capabilities.
And we have moved from models
with millions of parameters
to hundreds of billions and
even trillions these days.
And every step in that
evolution in the model size
demands a lot more from
the infrastructure,
which brings us to the third point.
Scale requirements have exploded.
Modern AI training is not
just about managing GPUs.
It's also about making sure that you get
the best out of all the
other infrastructures,
like compute and storage.
And what we also observe
is customers never just run
a training inside the single
cluster that they have.
They run a variety of diverse
workloads in the same cluster
to actually share the capacity.
They run their inference workloads.
And we also observe startups
running domain specific trained models
to high throughput inference services.
You know, this projection from Gartner
is absolutely stunning.
95% of new AI workloads
is gonna run on Kubernetes,
dramatically from 30 increase,
dramatic increase from
30% from what's today.
And what this is Kubernetes
is evolving beyond
the general purpose container orchestrator
to become the defacto substrate
for the AI/ML workloads.
We launched EKS Ultra Clusters in July
and we worked really
closely with anthropic,
one of our customers, to
address the challenges
that they were facing in their
critical AI/ML workloads.
While we initially
developed this capability
with AI in mind, what we are observing
is customers like to use
this Ultra Cluster setup
for other workloads.
These clusters can scale beyond
like close to a hundred thousand nodes
and they can harness up to
800,000 GPUs in a single cluster
or 1.6 million trainee max accelerators.
And we are proud that we
have achieved the scale,
while maintaining full
Kubernetes conformance.
This means you can use
your existing tools,
infrastructure, workflows,
without any modification
just at a larger scale.
And this graph here illustrates
what running AI workloads
in practice means.
We observe our customers,
like I mentioned,
running multiple distinct workloads.
In our testing, we orchestrated
three distinct workload
types simultaneously.
You see here we have
training stateful sets.
We also have fine tuning jobs
and inference worker sets.
As you can see, we have pushed the system
to handle up to a hundred
thousand concurrent pods scale
up to a hundred thousand concurrent pods
in a really short duration.
You see the climb up in
few minutes actually.
And you can see rapid scaling events,
where thousands of resources
of provision at rapid time,
like across all these three
different workload types.
And the key point here is
managing the scale reliably
is about maintaining
consistent performance
at any duration in this
lifecycle of the workloads.
And this is exactly what we
have, how we've reimagined
our control plane architecture to achieve.
Let's look at the EKS
control plane here, right.
Today, the control plane stores
and manages clusters state
in etcd.
And at the heart of the cluster is etcd,
managing both your cluster configuration.
And we actually run three etcd
nodes in a single cluster.
And it serves as the backbone
for the entire cluster,
storing all configuration data
and the state of your Kubernetes objects.
It uses the raft consensus protocol
to ensure the data
consistency across all nodes.
And there's also an NVCC layer,
which is multi-version concurrency control
that manages concurrent to the data
and provides the key isolation property
if you're actually having
multiple data write or reads
at the same time.
And the system here is anchored by BoltDB,
which is an in-memory key value store.
It's backed by a storage as well.
And we also see write ahead log,
which guarantees the durability
of your cluster state.
And we've ca carefully engineered
this setup to right size
as the demand requires,
but also making sure
that we have really regular rapid backups
to restore the cluster state
if in an unlikely event
of the cluster going down.
And this architecture
has served this well.
But as you'll see in the next slide,
we've made some
foundational changes to etcd
to support the Ultra Scale operations.
There are three innovations
that I wanna highlight here, right?
Like I'll start with in-memory database,
which is the BoltDB that I was mentioning.
We moved it from a
network attached storage
to an in-memory tempus based solution.
And this shift delivers order of magnitude
in performance improvements
in both read and write operations.
Second, we have partition the key spaces
that is stored inside the cluster
and that allows hot resource types
to be split into separate etcd clusters.
And our testing shows this,
the delivers up to five
times the right throughput,
while preserving the durability
and the rich AP somatics.
But the most critical
advancement we've actually done
is how we've offloaded
the consensus management.
We've moved from traditional
Raft-based consensus
to leveraging AWS' journal system.
Technology we've been perfecting
for over a decade now.
And it actually serves, its underpins
all of your favorite
services that you can,
many of your favorite services
that you can think of.
And this allows us to
scale etcd, etcd replicas
without being bounded by
core and requirements.
There's no need for etcd
peer-to-peer communication anymore.
And while this also delivers
ultrafast ordered data replication
with multi-AZ durability.
And together these three
innovations forms the foundation
that enables EK to support Ultra Clusters.
And here you see the new architecture
in EKS.
The key transformation, as I mentioned,
is how we handle consensus.
You see that on the left
is the storage layer,
the MVCC backed by BoltDB.
And on the right is the replication layer,
which is actually the consensus layer.
And we've integrated that
with AWS' battle tested
multi-AZ transaction journal.
And while we did that,
we've actually maintained
the familiar GRPC interface,
which meant that we
kept the same interface
between the current etcd
using Raft-based journal
and the new, sorry, Raft-based consensus
and the new journal based consensus.
And this like what this means
is you get massive improvements
without sacrificing
compatibility or durability.
So while we've enhanced
the cluster control plane,
we've also made significant improvements
to boost your application's
performance and reliability
with four key advancements.
First, we've introduced
multi-network interface support
for pods, enabling network bandwidth
up to a hundred gigabytes per second.
It's critical for AI workloads
moving massive data sets.
Second, we've also implemented
concurrent download
and unpacking of images
using in our new container runtime,
based on our SOCI image pool.
And what that allows us to do
is cut the container image
poles in half the time
that it takes today.
And for network efficiency,
we've moved from individual
IP assignments to your pods
to prefix delegation that assigns
a CIDR range for an instance at chart.
And this dramatically
improves node launch rates
up to threefold while optimizing
your VPC address range.
And finally, we've also launched
auto repair capabilities
for all of your compute,
including the accelerated compute.
We automatically detect and
replace your unhealthy nodes
to maintain consistent performance.
And let's talk about the real
world impact here, right?
The adoption of GPU workloads
in EKS has been remarkable.
Since 2024, we've seen GPU
instance usage with EKS
more than double.
And while AI and ML remains
significant drivers,
of course, we are seeing GP
adoption across various domains.
We see scientific simulations.
We see video processing at
scale, real-time rendering,
and high performance computing.
And know, while these are
groundbreaking capabilities
for massive workloads, we asked ourselves
a fundamental question, how can we bring
this performance improvements
to all of our customers?
I'm sure not everyone needs
a hundred thousand nodes cluster,
but I think every customer deserves
predictable high performance
control plane operations,
like whether you're running
your microservices platform
or managing enterprise
critical applications.
And we are bringing the
performance benefits
of our ultra scale
architecture for all clusters.
And I'm really excited
to introduce the Provision Control Plane.
It's a first of kind offering
that brings the performance benefits
of our ultra scale architecture
to all EKS clusters.
At its core, the Provision Control Plane
gives you the ability to select
high performance control
plane scaling tiers
with pre-allocated capacity.
Think of it as shifting
from on demand capacity
with auto scaling behind
to a provision reserve capacity model
for your control plane.
And it's particularly
valuable for any workload
that demands predictable performance.
Whether you're running AI/ML training
or you need consistent parts scaling rates
or operating multi-tenant platform,
you all expect the control plane
to have a better performance
as your workload scales.
And there are three key benefits
in Provision Control Plane.
First, you can provision
your control plane capacity,
eliminating the uncertainty
of dynamic scaling,
which is what happens today.
The cluster control
plane scales up and down
based on the workloads that you
are putting on the workload,
load you're putting on the cluster.
And this means you'll have
consistent predictable performance
for your critical workloads.
No more worrying about
control plane scaling delays
during critical operations.
Second, you gain access to
increased compute capacity.
We are talking about multiples
of standard performance levels
and you have, you get
capabilities of like processing
up to 6,800 concurrent API
requests in our highest tier.
And third, you can set up
the control plane tiers
to handle unexpected demand spikes.
And this is particularly valuable
when you're planning
for high traffic events.
And we have designed these
options with flexibility in mind.
As you can see, EKS now offers
two distinct control plane modes.
On the left, we call standard
and on the right is provisioned,
and you can switch between
them based on your needs.
And the standard mode, which
remains our default option.
Like I said, the control
plane scales up and down
as you put the load on it.
Obviously, there's some
delay in between scaling
between the run levels that we have today.
And this is perfect for
general purpose workloads,
as we, as you do today.
With provision mode, you're pre-allocating
the specific tiers for
guaranteed capacity.
And as your workload requirements evolve,
you can adjust your control
plane configuration accordingly.
And it's super easy to
either create a new cluster
or update an existing
cluster to provision mode.
You pick that capacity tier
and during the create or
you can actually do it during the update.
And I wanna dive
into the specific capabilities each year
offers for clusters.
Each year is engineered
around three critical
aspects that directly impact
your workload's
responsiveness and stability.
First, API request concurrency.
This determines how many operations
your cluster can handle simultaneously.
Think of this as your ability
or your cluster's ability to multitask,
whether you're rolling out deployments
or you're scaling applications,
you're handling health checks.
And higher concurrency means faster,
more responsive operations.
Pod scheduling rate is crucial
for your workload agility.
Like it's about how quickly your cluster
can respond to scaling events
or recover from disruptions.
And this becomes particularly
vital in any AI/ML workflows
where you need to rapidly
orchestrate training jobs
or scale inference services.
The cluster database size
is the third dimension here.
It ensures you have sufficient headroom
for your application metadata,
which stored, which is
stored on the CD side.
It's usually your config
map, your Secrets,
your resource like pods and
namespace and all of that stuff.
And each tier maintains
a 16 GB cluster size
and which we have found optimum
for most workload patterns.
And these tiers represent
carefully engineered performance levels
that match real world operational needs.
You know, we made it really, really easy
to consume these capabilities.
Like with just a simple CLIR command
or click in the console,
you can configure your desired
control plane capacity.
I encourage you all to try
it out on your new cluster
or an existing cluster.
So now that I've shared how we are pushing
the boundaries of the scale
and performance with EKS,
I'm excited to introduce
Niall Mullen here,
senior director of cloud
infrastructure at Netflix.
And Netflix operates
some of the world's largest
container platforms,
serving hundreds of millions
of customers globally.
And they've been at the forefront
of cloud native innovation
and their journey to EKS is a
story of evolution and scale.
Niall, over to you.
- Thank you.
Hi, everyone. My name's Niall Mullen.
I lead what we call cloud
infrastructure engineering
at Netflix.
Am I in the right place? Yep.
So, this is a story more about how moving
existing large stuff to manage services
or to have someone else do
some of the heavy lifting
can be done.
I'm gonna talk a bit about
our background in Netflix,
what makes us unique, different,
and hard to do this with
on our journey to EKS
over the past two years.
So, compute at Netflix.
We have a lot of compute.
We're super dense compared
to most AWS customers.
Not alone do we have 300
million paying customers
that we have to run a website at,
which is more like a billion
user profiles or users
and that takes a lot of compute.
We have large scale personalization
to make all of those predictions appear
for what you want to watch
before you even know
what you want to watch.
And that takes a lot of compute.
But even that is dwarfed by
the thousands of hours of video
we're shooting every week in AK
that we're converting to run
from everything from your
10-year-old Roku device
to the latest AK TVs.
And not alone is it
just this week's video.
We're constantly re-encoding
the entire back catalog of
Netflix to use the latest codex
and to be rendered in
all those resolutions.
In addition to that, we have
a rapidly growing ads business
and a burgeoning gaming business,
each of which are large
sources of compute.
So, we have a lot of compute at Netflix.
And from talking to pure customers
or other large customers at AWS,
the proportion of our
spend that is compute based
is 50 to 100% higher than
many other large customers.
So let's talk about the setup at Netflix.
We came to the cloud 15 years ago.
So actually a majority
of compute at Netflix
still runs on a very mature,
very well-run EC2 workflow
that enables developers
build Java and node services primarily
and runs some direct on EC2.
A large minority of compute
though runs on a system
called Titus that we delivered
eight or so years ago.
It's a majority of actual
service counted at Netflix.
So most new code at Netflix
gets written by default on this.
And it's a large scale
multi-tenant container platform,
which effectively does
container as a service.
We originally built it on Mesos.
We shifted it to Kubernetes
seamlessly under the hood
about five years ago.
And that's the scope of what
we're gonna talk about today
in terms of what we took EKS to work with.
However, there's a lot of key differences
as to why we're even
more awkward than that.
We run four core streaming regions,
a couple of additional twin regions
for some of our encoding gaming use cases.
We run a regional availability model.
That means when we have problems
we flip an entire region
in about five minutes.
In the middle of October,
AWS had a bad day,
happens about once a decade or so.
We had a bad 15 minutes and
we were out of US-East-1.
Secondly, we have the
concept of the trough.
There's a diurnal cycle in
almost everybody's services,
which can be as much runs to
about 45% delta from the peak
to the trough we find in many services.
And that's basically
hundreds of thousands of CPUs
that are sitting idle at
different points of the day.
And you have two choices.
You can either judge what's the sweet spot
to how much you purchase on demand
or how much you purchase
reserved instances
or you buy the whole lot
in reserved instances
and you pack every cycle of that
with all of that time insensitive
work I described earlier.
We run about 97% of our reserved instances
as utilized doing something.
I'm not saying we run them all well,
that's a different argument, but we do.
The main point is we are
moving a lot of compute around,
a lot of the time, more so
than perhaps anybody else.
Let's talk about some of our scale.
We have four primary regions,
hundreds of thousands of containers
in each of those regions.
But when we talk about
what we have to plan for
in adopting a service like EKS,
it's not just a steady state launch rate
and it's not just even the
region evacuation launch rate
when we're getting outta US-East-1.
It's when a hundred million people
are watching Mike Tyson
get his lights punched out
and we have to get out of US-East-1
and that's what we have to plan for.
So when we first talked to
EKS about this four years ago,
three years ago, three years ago,
I think it was three years ago here,
the answer was hell no
when we sketch the kind
of launch rates we need.
And I have to give kudos to Pinterest,
who brought EKS on a journey through 2023,
that brought us to the
point that two years ago,
it was, well, we don't even need to double
what you guys can do.
And so, we started on our journey.
We don't do cluster as a service.
We're different on that front as well.
We run less than 20 production
clusters in our four regions
and we believe that the
high percentile scale
and availability story of
running very large clusters,
multi-tenant on very
large boxes works better.
But that makes us weird and different
for a service like EKS, who has to cater
to hundreds of thousands
of different customers
and all of their oddities.
So we've up to 10,000 machines,
big ones, 24 and 48 excels per region.
We've about 80,000 containers or pods.
We use those pretty interchangeably
for how this is configured
in each of those clusters.
etcd is still running
north of five gigabyte,
though it was more than
twice that at one point.
We've had to do a lot of
work to bring that down.
That is one of the sets
of changes we have to do.
And we run launch rates
of 70,000 instances
in a five minute period
or sorry, containers
when we flip regions.
So, why EKS if we have all this already?
One of our core engineering
principles of Netflix
is built only when necessary.
And we built all of this stuff
that I've described
over the last 15 years,
because it was necessary,
because there was nothing
there to do things
at the scale we wanted to do it.
And we still want to build
lots of things today,
but we don't need to build
what others can provide.
So we want to offload
the undifferentiated work
and make scale somebody else's,
in this case AWS's problem.
Let's have a quick look at
what we did have to build.
I'm not gonna go into the
details of this slide,
I'll talk through what we had to do.
But the green pieces were
the integrations we had to do
with EKS.
The red pieces were all of the services
and the existing code of
ours that we got to delete
as we moved the control plane to EKS.
So, here's the one text heavy slide
that we have to read through.
This is the list of what
we spent our time doing.
We worked for about a
nine month period with EKS
to work through getting their
scale to where we needed to
and doing these integrations.
We had to use EKS itself.
We had a lot of changes to make
around our regional control planes,
which are consolidated
in account to give EKS
its own space, and its own control plane,
and its own VPC so we could isolate it.
We have changes to our identity model.
We have our own identity
model, which works
in both inside and outside AWS.
We have to integrate with IAM
for the EKS control plane integrations.
And we had some integrations
with CloudWatch to do
as the Kubernetes logs go into CloudWatch
and some prometheus
integrations to support that.
But all in all, we were
able to work through this
with a fairly small engineering team
and we took the aggressive goal
that we were going to, sorry.
So we ended with a system
that as you create a container
create on the new one.
We decided to migrate the
entire fleet in one quarter.
Getting long-term metrics of Netflix
is another bug bearer of
mine, but it's a pain.
But this is the tail
end of that migration.
And within, we ran a
little over a quarter,
about 11 days over and we've migrated
every last container
from our existing system
to launching on the new EKS control plane.
And there's not a lot
of pain in this story.
Nothing ever goes smoothly.
And we did find the limits.
EKS doesn't like 120,000
pods inside a single cluster.
At least, it didn't back in March.
I'm excited to see the
hyperscale announcements
that Eswar has been talking about today.
I'm gonna go and test
out some of those limits.
And what we find at our mutation rates
is that the numbers that
EKS say they support,
they support a little less
when we're spinning the pods
at the rate we are.
And it was so successful.
We also run a federation
layer above those clusters
where we choose which pods
go into which cluster.
Some of them need to
be in the same cluster.
Some want to be in different clusters
for availability regions.
We've also moved that
federation layer to CD
ahead of schedule because of
how smooth this experience was.
So, what's next?
We spent this year evolving
the tightest data plane
to be less weird.
It consisted of a Virtual Kubelet
of like 60,000 lines of custom code
and that was a bit a
bridge too far to bring
to AWS or to EKS.
So now, it's running on the stock Kubelet
and we're going through another one
of those crazy migrations,
which we're racing towards
year end to try and be done.
We'll probably be about
11 days over again.
But that opens the door to
an EKS data plane migration
in the future.
EKS Hybrid Nodes open the
door for use cases we have,
where we're seeing more
and more edge use cases
for our gaming and increasingly
heterogeneous encoding
use cases
EKS Auto Mode allows us
potentially getting rid
of having to look after the OS
for many of these use cases.
So, there are all the things
we're looking at in this coming year.
We're also experimenting
with thinner containers,
If any of you can do the math
in some of those earlier slides,
you'll figure that our containers are big,
spanning many CPUs in many cases,
but we're seeing more and
more thin container use cases.
So, this is what we're
gonna work on in 2026
and hopefully, we'll come
back and tell a story
about how we migrated the data
plane to EKS in future years.
So, thank you for time and
the opportunity to talk here.
Sorry, handover
(audience clapping)
- The handover.
All right, thank you Niall.
Looking forward to you continue
to pushing the boundaries
of what we can support at scale.
Okay, so finally, the title
with seven minutes to go
of actually what's coming next.
We've done a lot of work this year,
but we love unsatisfied customers
and we know we have more to do.
This isn't an exact quote,
but it's one that I've put together
from an aggregation of talking
to hundreds of customers
over the last year or two,
whether it's newer Kubernetes adopters.
Even existing customers who are
early adopters of Kubernetes
are realizing that it's not
really useful to my business
to tweak every last
add-on every last setting,
own every last thing.
It's the same refrain of
I want to use Kubernetes.
It's become the standard.
I want to use the tooling.
I don't wanna think
about clusters, upgrades,
any of the hard parts.
So there's often,
you know, there's pure
technology companies
out there, right, whose goal
is to solve these hard problems at scale.
And we have customers
who also need to solve
these hard problems, but
they have different focuses.
You might be in healthcare, gaming,
pharmaceutical, airlines,
There's all kinds of different
industries out there.
You don't necessarily have
the time to focus on running
and managing large open
source projects yourself.
And so, you know, how
do you use technology
without becoming a pure
technology company?
I think every company
these days wants to say
they're a tech company,
but that's not really
what the end core business focus is
of a lot of these companies out there.
And you come to a conference like this,
you're seeing a lot of
projects, innovations,
and how do you go back and
make use of that yourselves.
Open source software,
you know, contributing
to several small projects,
running it small scale with open source,
doing it yourself, that's doable.
As soon as you start getting
to 20 open source projects,
putting that together, running at scale,
you need a lot of time and expertise.
And so really, what we think about at EKS
is taking open standards,
combining that with AWS,
and accelerating your time to value.
It's using all of EKS
without having to manage
these open source projects yourselves.
So, it's lowering the cost of
entry to run these projects.
Every type of workload
runs on EKS these days.
We just talked a lot about AI/ML.
You heard Niall talk about streaming
and encoding, gaming, web
applications, data processing.
You name the workload,
it's running on EKS,
and so we have a very broad
diverse customer base,
types of workloads.
We're gonna make sure our
service works for all of those.
Of course, AI/ML is the
hot topic these days,
but there's lots of other workloads,
Stateful workloads, in
particular, Spark, Flink,
we wanna make those easier.
How do you upgrade stateful workloads?
EKS, I think, we've showed
this slide in a few years.
We started with just the
managed control plane.
That's the really hard part of Kubernetes.
Running etcd, scaling,
patching API servers,
it's not easy to do.
And that's where we started back in 2018.
Over the time, you know, we've
moved beyond just clusters
into hybrid running
compute outside of AWS.
Managing more of the platform components.
So EKS capabilities, which
I talked about this year,
are launched this year,
will continue to take on
heavy lifting of some of those components
that you're running in
addition to the cluster,
and then the developer experience.
What if there was a world
where you could just give EKS
your application manifest?
You didn't even have to create
a cluster in the first place.
You just gave us the
application you wanna run,
let us do the heavy lifting,
like Niall just talked
about a federated layer
above all of their clusters
that they've built to
figure out where pods go.
We'd love to do something like that,
so you can get Kubernetes
without even having to
think about clusters.
So, what are our priorities
for the next three years?
One, critical workload
patterns at any scale.
That's really what we've
talked about today.
We just talked about all the
different workload patterns,
the scale requirements,
just keep getting larger.
We're, you know, we're gonna have to look
at splitting out across multiple clusters,
because at a certain
scale, you just run into,
this is as large as a
single cluster can get.
How can we make running workloads
across multiple clusters easier?
AWS integrations, this
is a large part of me
and Eswar's job is going and working
with the other teams within AWS,
making sure that they're
building the right things.
Kubernetes is really the
front door to the cloud
for a lot of customers we talk to.
They're not going necessarily
through 50 AWS services.
They're going through Kubernetes
and the EBS driver provisions EBS,
the S3 driver provisions S3.
They're using AWS through Kubernetes,
and it's really important
for us to make sure
that these other services across AWS
work well for Kubernetes native customers.
And so, that's a big part of it.
You'll see us working with other teams,
more integrations coming.
Meeting your workloads where they are.
That slide I showed earlier,
everything from EKS Distro,
which is take it, run it yourself
anywhere possible on a
jet, on a cruise ship,
EKS in the cloud, and anywhere in between.
We're working on improving our story
of managing clusters on outposts,
so supporting the new skew
and server types of outposts
that are coming.
We will continue to make
sure we meet your workloads
where they are.
I wrote simplify platform building here.
It may be a little controversial
to say eliminate platform building.
We wanna just launch more and
more managed capabilities,
so you don't have to run
or need huge platform teams
in order to use EKS.
We really don't think you
should need massive teams
to run Kubernetes.
Again, use Kubernetes
without having to operate it.
And then, lastly is just,
you know, accelerating
the flywheel of innovation.
We continue to work in the
community, open source projects.
Generally, I'd say our philosophy
is if there's an existing standard
in the open source
community, we will take it
and we we'll run with it.
We did that with the
launch of managed Argo
that you saw this year.
Something like Karpenter
was one where we went
out into the community,
there was an existing
standard cluster auto scaler.
We thought we could do better.
And that's a, it's a big decision to say,
"There's an existing standard.
You know, we're gonna build
an entirely new project."
There's, I don't know, I
think a meme at 16 standards,
we're gonna go do the new
one, now there's 17 standards.
But in this case, we actually
built the new standards.
Nearly every cloud provider
supports a Karpenter.
And then there's other cases
like ACK AWS controllers
for Kubernetes.
More of a just open
source AWS only project,
but there's reasons to open source that.
So, we'll continue to
work in the community.
Our public roadmap.
I get emails every time
there's something somebody
makes a comment on here.
So, I check this every day.
It's a way to get feedback to us.
There's more sessions coming.
So if you want to learn
more about EKS capabilities,
if you want to learn more
about the container network observability,
and if you want to go even deeper
than what Eswar talked about today
on the high scale ultra scale performance,
I believe that one's a 500 level,
which is one of the few 500 levels.
So if you want to get really deep
on some of the architecture
changes, go check out that one.
And yeah, some resources, best
practices, guide blueprints.
And that's it. Thank you very much.
(audience clapping)